vous travailler sur ma fille je n'ai jamais de
bijou ou astucieusement quand je vais
demander un avantage votre dossier est épouvantable
tellement de votre courte vie vous vous êtes
comporté comme un voyou je vous condamne à
300 heures de remboursement de la communauté mais
ils m'ont quand même passé  regarde, je suis désolé mais c'est un
café de 15 minutes trop tard va te faire faire les
ongles mec s'il
te plait hey con source du code de sécurité sous l'espace
pour regarder l'échantillon d'un
whisky qui est tout simplement hors de prix
c'est ces derniers temps que le bouclier pourrait soulever un
excès de 1 million de pièces qui vous donnent
une grosse dinde j'adore ça je me fais prendre à faire
n'importe quoi rit je suppose cinq ans une
liste dans ma guêtre je  veux dire qui va
enlever une écume comme de la glace
parle pour toi-même de même ce que
je n'aime pas j'en suis un au moins envoie tes
chambres veux blesser Magnus ou Lucas sympa
nous avons tous des criminels en
service communautaire qui postulent pour le culte de la chaleur
Yippity d'Apollon et  ev  il Nicole une telle
étincelle par un regard de frittata
j'en ai besoin d'un ici dans le désert mange l'homme pablor
l'étude la terre promise
hey Nia Peter ici ce [ __ ] d'
homme poubelle tu t'es évanoui
seulement ceux-ci avec un kilt tu ne
dors plus bureau off
dit-elle  grâce à ce qui t'arrive
[Musique]